Are you totally nervous too? Oh
yeah. On like dying right now.
A viral New York Times article featured
36 questions that could supposedly make
any two people fall in love.
We wanted to see what would happen if
we ask these questions to two complete
strangers on a blind date.
I'm Danny. I am single.
I've never really been in a relationship,
but um,
what I'm looking for an in
person. I Dunno, just fun
at this moment. I'm really
scared actually, but like,
excited, nervous. Hopefully my
hands don't sweat or something.
Hi, I'm Danny. Andrew,
nice to meet you too.
I'm Andrew. I'm right now I'm just
trying to meet people and you know,
have a general idea of what type of
person that would like to meet but not
trying to put on any blinders
and what can I TV like, um,
peppermint. Peppermint
is fun. Are you excited?
I'm excited and nervous. Yeah, me too.
Would you like to be famous and in
what way? No, no. Never really. No,
I don't think so.
I feel like that would be like so much
pressure to have to like be something for
everyone. I think you'd have
to be something for everyone
when she, no, not really.
I mean, I wouldn't, I wouldn't feel
like obligated to be famous for,
I don't know.
Um,
I guess be famous for myself or
be famous for something I'm done.
I brought value like a famous singer.
I mean,
it'd be cool to be talented
like that. Right. But um, no,
I wouldn't want to change for people.
I feel like obligated it be who they
wanted me to be. If they like you,
they like you. If they don't, they don't.
Yeah, I get that it got some tea. Yeah,
that'd be great. It's that Steve
Know. I don't know if it is,
does it taste pepper many at all?
Is it just straight water?
It's just nice warm water. You want to
pour it back in or is that weird? Is that,
I don't think so.
It's going to go to all over or are
you totally nervous too? Oh yeah.
On like dying. Right. It's okay.
If a crystal ball could tell you the truth
about yourself, your life, the future,
or anything else, what would you want
to know? Hold on. I want to know.
I would want to know who
and when I get married.
Really? Yeah. You would want to know
that. Yeah. That's cool. What about you?
What would you want to know? I don't know
that I'd want to know anything really.
Yeah,
like just being surprised by life and I
wouldn't want to know when I was going
to die. No, I get it. Like
some people can sometimes,
like if you know you're going to die,
like you can really truly live because
you know you've got like limited time,
but I'm not sure I would choose that.
Yeah.
I think it would change too much
how I would live. Like it wouldn't,
you wouldn't really live.
You would be so focused on like
getting things done before. Yeah. Yeah.
I'll let you ask that. My five. All
right. I'm going to find a good one.
Hence it doing this again. I'll see. Oh,
there we go. There we go. Crashed it.
I like your little sayings.
Crushed it sick. It's really
cool. It's very San Diego.
Cheers.
What roles do love and affection
play in your life? Oh Gosh. Yeah.
I think I get a lot of love and affection
from like my family and my close
friends. So I don't know.
That's like a weird to ask.
Like what roles did they play?
Like a big one I guess for me cause
I like right now I'm so new to La.
Like I don't have anybody here yet.
I know I will.
But like what would be fun? I don't open
up easy. No. It's hard for me to get team.
Like it's not hard for
me to get to know people.
Like I get to know people
really well and quickly,
but it's hard for me to really get to know
people. Like it takes a while. Exactly.
Yeah, I get that. And I work all the
time. So right now I'm a personal trainer.
I work in Beverly Hills
as a personal trainer.
It's fun giving people to the point
of where like they fall in love with
themselves. That's better than
they need us job. That's awesome.
That's really cool. I like you're
finding fulfillment in that too. Yeah.
Cause like not a lot of people
get to do that, you know,
find fulfillment in their jobs and I'm
young enough to where I can figure it out.
Yeah, totally. What was the
question? I don't remember
complete this sentence.
I wish I had someone with
whom I can share like
I want to just my life with.
It's like somebody that is always there
for you and you can like come home if
you ever had a bad day
at work and be like,
this thing happened and they
just kind of are there for you.
The good and the bad thing.
Like, yeah. What about you?
Why cooking? Rarely. Oh my God. You Cook.
I'm a huge cook. I cook all the time.
What's your favorite food
and chicken popper? Gosh,
I saw Hungarian dish. I guess
my dad's family was. Yeah,
but it's like a chicken and like a
pep Rica grabby or love pepper gun.
It's so good. Yeah. I'm
gonna have to figure it out.
I can make it for you sometime.
I'll be down. Let's do it.
So cook off the we shut.
That'd be fun.
Tell your partner something
you like about them already?
Um,
I feel like you have a very like,
calming presence and I really enjoy that
where it's like I'm not as stressed.
That's good. Yeah. I'm super nervous so
it doesn't really come off. I feel like.
Yeah. I feel like my face is like
seizing up because I'm so nervous. No,
you seem very like chill and like that.
Yeah.
I was gonna say like you seem
very like relaxed and easy going,
which is not something I've
run into in La at all. Really.
Like after the first couple of weeks I
was like not going give me them to be
here. Like it's just gonna be hard. Yeah,
you're very genuine. That's what it is.
Okay. It's genuine. It was nice.
Really. I don't know. Real,
which is so hard because I feel like la
is a city that worships everything and
how I use nothing. Yeah. Gosh.
Final task without speaking. Stare into
each other's eyes for four minutes.
Four minutes. That's a
long time. Oh my gosh.
Okay.
We'll you for four minutes pretty easily.
We can't talk while you're looking
at each other for four minutes.
It's a challenge. I'm always
down for a child. Oh my God.
I don't think anybody's ever
looked at numbers. 40 minutes.
Yeah.
Okay.
I was definitely really,
really, really, really, really,
really nervous and I got a lot less
nervous and it was very different than I
expected.
She was really cool.
She's like super pretty.
I feel like a lot of it was,
I was like, wow, this guy's really
attractive. Sweet, down to Earth,
just generally nice person.
Then I was thinking, wow,
nobody's ever looked at me this
long or like this ever I think.
And it felt really nice.
I felt like everything she
was was like real. Hmm.
I like that.
That was a lot easier.
It went so good. She's like,
beautiful. So there's that
and he's so nice. So I was like,
really? That was really fun.
They're probably gonna ask us like,
what'd you go out again? But yeah.
Should we run it for him?
And I kind of expected it to be like,
you guys want to go on a second
date? Sure. Yeah, let's do it.
And then like follow me on
Instagram. Cool. Here's my handle.
And then like never talk again
like our pictures occasionally,
but like I don't get a feeling like
that is what's going to happen.
So we'll see. I might be totally wrong.
I've totally misread this, but we'll see.
Do you want to go out again
again? I would love to. Yeah. Um,
I have a day off Saturday. I have Saturday
off. You want to do something? Yeah,
we say, okay, we should do the hike to
the Hollywood sign. Oh yeah. I'm sorry.
I feel like that's like a very
like, hey, welcome to la thing.
Rolling.
Okay.
Hey guys. Hi. So this is our first date.
Second date. The second day technique
is the first day was bill. All right.
Technically second day we're going
to go hiking on the Hollywood sign,
but it was like a hundred degrees, so
that was a no go. So we went to the beach,
flip the camera around as a foot
around. We'll just go like, okay.
They have those in California.
Apparently.
I've been told allegedly we're
not sure yet. Anyway, yeah,
that's, that's it. There
we go. Thanks. Bye.
Yeah.